what a do son this week we did wrong
leaf with the Game of Thrones by George
RR mark
man this is gonna be a [ __ ] so this
book split up into a bunch of different
narrative each chapter is told from the
perspective of one of the main
characters like Ned
Daenerys John are you I could go on play
but I'm gonna break down this bad boy by
getting all geographical on your ass one
plot taking place on the west side one
on the east side and the other up and a
big-ass ice wall up in the north we'll
get to that later but for now let's see
what's going down over here Ned Stark is
a top dog of a hood called Winterfell
the swollen scaned him in the north
after taking care of some brother who
couldn't keep his word Ned started
trucking it back to Winterfell but
before he get a say man I'm gonna wrap
them stock colors and adopt some of
these dire wolves right so he'd get a
direwolf for every child he got it's
three legit sons Rob Brandon recon his
two daughters are Ian Sansa and his
bastard love child Jon Snow
you know the pretty one so old man ready
to chillax back at his crib when a King
Robert Baratheon Swank in the town and
there'd be like Oh what you doing the
king like son you heard the news my
right-hand man Jon Arryn just got mark
ain't nobody know why Ned like knows
word you're gonna get my back and be my
new advisor man that ain't really my
style but when Ned's woman Catelyn get
word from her sister Lysa that it was
Robert's Queen and her family Lannisters
that were behind the hit Ned like kid
let's do this King now the Lannisters be
another one of the great crews of the
Seven Kingdoms King Robert is married to
Cersei Lannister and her twin bro Jaime
Lannister is supposed to protect the
king in case anyone trying to step later
mans boy branch is minding his own
business when shorty walk in or search
he getting some of that bro sauce from
Jaime now that ain't right they gotta
make sure Brando snitch so he tosses
little ass out of window now he ain't
dead but dog is dumb and don't remember
nothing so Ned has the King's Landing
with his two girls side slit and are you
Joffrey the 12 year old son of the king
assigns his future man he's always
talking smack and trying to start when
he little are you though shorty show him
what's up
arias direwolf gets all up on that head
and our
not only swipes his blade but throws it
in the damn River Joffrey was like a
little [ __ ] and Solvers direwolf gets
rekt by the Queen since Arya's already
skipped town things between the Starks
and the Lannisters ain't looking so good
back in Winterfell some Hood as brother
trying to ice little brand while he's
snooze
so Catelyn had the keys landed to tell
Ned what went down man hook up with
Barrett's the master of Secrets and the
Kings sheisty as adviser Petyr Baelish
who like Apes that knife belong to
Tyrion Lannister the little door brother
to Cersei and Jaime
so Catelyn hits up her sister Liza and
puts Tyrion on lockdown in her crib
carrying a their long no brother shakes
them haters off after some gangster
named Bron when's his freedom by reckon
some fool eventually man figure out the
secret I put Jon Arryn in the dirt drive
rain even the kids were just son he the
inbred love child of Cersei and Jaime
Lannister hmm that man got no right to
the crown
when sense he realized what Ned no she
like damn I got to get that crown or
Joffrey's head before the word gets out
so girl plots on her hubby and King
Robert gets ganked in a hunting accident
now that he did Ned grabs Petyr Baelish
to say dog I need some funds to get my
back while I challenged Geoffrey's claim
to the throne Benglis like show thing
blood I got you but Baelish betrays him
Joffrey becomes king and slices man's
damn head off ice cold when Ned's oldest
boy Rob here his daddy been done dirty
he started building a fat crew of
northerners after making the Lannister
army his [ __ ] everybody started calling
him the king of the north swag all right
so this is what we got going on on this
big ice cube up in the north called the
wall which keep out these savage humans
called wildlings and whatever the hell
others are there for messing with the
Seven Kingdoms Ned's bastard Jon Snow
grinding as a man of the Nights Watch
which basically is a crew of Burgess who
devote their lives to guarding the wall
John always looking out for this fat-ass
bruh named Samwell here nice dude and
all but dude can't do [ __ ] with a sword
later Jon found out that some of his
Nights Watch home he's got smoked in
combat and there
been going off thrill up in here they
straight up become crazy undead hustlers
called others so when these haters try
to throw now John saves the Lord
Commander from getting wreck when John
get word that his daddy been marked he
tried to join his bro Rob and a good
fight but after some Night Watch big
dogs telling me best big duty over love
he just like man
so John packs up them nuts and stays a
man in the Nights Watch on the east side
two siblings named viserys and danerys
targaryen trying to crew up with some
soldiers see that daddy was rocking a
crown before Robert Baratheon so them
two kids thinking that throat is theirs
so the saris allies with this badass
mother named Karl Drago my slaying of
Daenerys is handsome as a wedding
present
Daenerys get three petrified dragon eggs
Primos says nobody dumped eat the dragon
in ages but Sarah's always talking mash
to Daenerys laughing her up like he hold
her ass up but when he finally threatens
Daenerys and her baby she got coming
couches Isis dad he later drago gets
shanked in a battle and some healers say
she gonna help her girl just make it
worse and Drago gets so dead in the head
that Daenerys just ended for all toe up
Daenerys start to burn her hubby's body
with them three dragon eggs then she
decides get I'm gonna walk my ass over
and say that fire cuz why not when I
fired them blazing all that's left is
Daenerys is chilling with three baby
dragons sucking at those titties the end
alright let's start with the basics like
you probably guessed from the series
title this book strapped with images of
Ice and Fire
now a lot of them are going to jump
right on out at you for example that
star crew all lifestyle the stark motto
is winter is coming and Nance sword even
called ice plus we got them ice-cold
other brothers roaming around on the
fiery side we got Daenerys chilling the
flames and heading up a brand new posse
of three fire-breathing dragons but we
also give some subtle shoutouts to Ice
and Fire
when somebody from the Nights Watch gets
wasted by one of the others the pale
sword bit through the ring nail beneath
his arm the young lord cried out in pain
blood well between the Rings
it's steamed in the cold and the
droplets seem red as fire where they
touch the snow
don't trip homegirl cuz that ain't all
we got some pretty tight symbols in the
novel - my personal fave is a direwolves
where Ned and his church find a mama
died wood from page 18
mama dub got a foot of shattered antlers
stuck all up in her throat if you open
up your eyes and peep the house
Baratheon sizzle you'll see that they
got a stag front and center whereas the
star crew got a great down look so that
wolf died from an antler foreshadowing
that old man stock tried to get his
wreck in that house Baratheon gonna have
something to do with them dog was also
telling us a little some something bout
the owners brand say on page 21 that Jon
Snow's wolf was the first to open his
eyes while the others still blind
likewise Josh snow see a budget that
other people don't
ambassador had to learn to notice things
to read the truth that people hid behind
their eyes plenty mo people's when I
came from Sun coz eyes and sight popping
up all over a game of Thrones that
badass serial Ferrell say he the most
throwed up warrior in town cuz of what
he called the scene opening your eyes is
all that is needing the heart lives and
the head plays tricks with us but the
eyes see true look with your eyes hear
with your ears taste with your mouth
smell with your nose fill with your skin
then comes to thinking afterward and
then that way knowing the truth when
it's go down and you got to go toe to
toe with some hater a real gangster
don't just keep his heart in check but
also his mind man you gotta chill out
observe everything around you and then
you get a little taste of the truth but
if this book showing us one thing is
that ain't nobody got a lock on truth
not even a really snug on the ball Ned
Stark
homeboy puts the truth the side twice
for the people he loves and pay for with
his head as the Lord Commander of the
Nights Watch preaching the things we
love destroy us every time in a world
where everybody backstabbing everybody
on the rag how's the brother gonna feel
like he got any control over his destiny
man well maybe the only power you can
really count on its power over yourself
tyrion dropping the same knowledge on
Jon Snow let me give you some counsel
bastard never forget what you are
for surely the world will not make it
your strength then it can never be your
weakness armor yourself
and it will never be used to hurt you if
they want to give you a name take it
make it your own then they can't hurt
you with it anymore so take the power
into your own hands and make sure to
pre-order the thug notes book for those
that don't know it's coming out in
August and it'll be the dopest breakdown
of the classes you'll ever read for real
and hey go check out another super-smart
channel called dnews and if you got Game
of Thrones on the mind check out that
video on how inbreeding messes with your
genes
Joffrey oh and one more thing I just
want to introduce you to the new host of
a new show on wisecrack this is Ella
darling and it's a sovereign size
they're awesome
hey the show's coming soon so make sure
to check them out
[Music]
you ever find yourself wondering about
ancient history maybe all the time maybe
some Egyptian mm-hmm a little bit of
French